but you think that it could possibly
just topple the united states
i do i think we might be looking at
um well let's put it this way i think
what i'm seeing in the street
reminds me far too much of maoism
uh and that if you uh attempt
a maoist takeover in the u.s
you will get a civil war so um
i am very concerned that we are much
closer to a brink
that frankly i i think we all know
is out there somewhere but that you
worry that
do you worry that right-wing crazies are
going to come
gunning for things well here's the
i'm hesitant to say right wing crazies
because
what i think the problem is i full well
understand
looking at people tearing apart cities
saying things that make no sense um
you know claiming that uninventing the
police
that you know abolishing them would be
progress
that they're unfortunately
the people that you're talking about
have more of a point than they should
which is this is
madness right so i don't want them to
have a point i don't want a civil war
what i want is for people to sober up
and stop
behaving in this way but i also having
seen a mini version of this
know better right um so
i would put on your radar if you're not
thinking about it yet
the coincidence of
shut down stem traveling with this
religious belief system that you and i
both see
is extremely important there is a reason
that this religious movement that we see
in our streets is also talking about
shutting down stem
and we saw this all in miniature at
evergreen they came after stem
also there was a reason that it was me
they came after they went after my
students to
in fact one of my a mixed race student
woman
whose mother's afro-caribbean
was actually confronted by the rioters
and accused of race trading for
being a science student so this
anti-science
belief system is infused into this
critical race theory
religion that we see
protesting and rioting and so the threat
that that poses to
our ability even if you had this
documentary that you're talking about
it would be i don't know what the it can
is there documentary burning
uh they will invent documentary burning
right
and effectively it will only reach those
who already
in some sense know better so i'm i'm
just watching this thing take over
people who should know better and so
that says something about the mechanism
of action the
arguments that are being deployed are
really low quality but the mechanism of
action is really
powerful the strategy is very very
strong it's a smart strategy
so i don't know where that leaves us now
as to your point about
it can't be podcasts i agree with you
and i've increasingly
started to wonder if one of the problems
that we face
is that the people who should be in a
leadership position
people who could say something could
shut down the bad arguments and
substitutes
that those people are i would say
trapped in the gig
economy and they don't have the power of
leaders because
everybody can click away they don't you
know a leader can tell you something you
don't
want to know but you need to know um
somebody who
you know you're deciding to watch them
and as soon as they start saying things
that you don't like you
go find somebody who says stuff you like
better that's not a leadership position
and so uh i wonder if part of what's
taking place is that
the transformation of the way we
interact with each other
has ruined the concept of leadership and
a leaderless movement is a dangerous
movement because it's inherently going
to subscribe to
um pleasant fantasies utopia among them
you know you're scaring me but
i want to venture this
if what we're really seeing is
a pendulum shift like on the campuses
like this is not remotely to minimize
what happened to you but
when that happened to you there were
many of us including you
who were thinking and i understand what
you're saying about the whole attitude
towards stem and how insidious that
could be but we were thinking
is this college is this what it's going
to be to be at a university from now on
and as i've been observing lately
in the historical sense that was
actually only a few years in the mid
teens that was kind of a fashion
and watch it happen tomorrow somewhere
but you notice there's a cluster of
events like that
and then it kind of stopped and i think
it was partly because of the pushback
against it from a lot of
sensible people it's not that i think
anybody was reading
an op-ed in the chronicle of higher
education and decided not to do it but
i'm not sure how these things happen but
society turned against people getting
beat up when they come to speak on the
campus and in this case
if that happens after about three years
and we've got about three years to wait
this out
if that happens the good thing that will
have come out of it is that i think it
has been resoundingly proven
that people like ta-nehisi coates are
wrong in their sense
that america is this place that's
utterly united against black people on
all levels and that nothing will ever
happen because all you have to do is
look at the color of a lot of those
crowds to see that there's a certain
kind of white person and it's not only
you know anti-fa it's not only college
students it's a lot of people
who have really changed and made this
country a different place than it was
even 25 years ago which to me feels like
five minutes ago
maybe that'll be the result but that
that could only have happened you get
into kind of
dime store hegel here with all of this
craziness going on right now
that might not be what happens though we
might be at a particular turning point
in which case you
are the wise one right now and i'm the
one who's assuming that hitler will go
away
i'm just hoping that i'm making some
kind of sense
can we agree that we are both rooting
for you to be right
i mean so strongly um here's here's my
concern i also thought that we were
actually turning the tide on college
campuses
and you know there's some reason to
think that what happened at reed for
example was very different than
evergreen even if it started out similar
but i actually think something else
explains
the fact that this has died down on
college campuses and it's less hopeful
which is that in some sense this is a
millennial delusion and i don't mean
it's all millennials
uh my wife and i you know heather we
taught uh mostly millennials for the
entire time we were teaching
and have a great many millennial friends
so we know there are lots of people in
that
generation who can think very carefully
but there's also
a kind of uh tendency to embrace
um this mode of thinking that has now
left college and it's now inside of all
these other institutions and so never
thought about that
the fact that we are seeing the same
battle
that we saw at evergreen now apparently
unfolding inside the new york times and
every other journalistic
apparatus that's to me not a hopeful
sign because it means that now
we're not dealing with the the toy
version we're dealing with this with all
of the stuff on which we depend
and uh that's not a it's not a hopeful
thought
no you're really making me think about
these things and um
the thing though is that college
generations reproduce themselves
and i get the idea that the people from
10 minutes ago
who were hollering on campuses are now
interns at the new york times or
something like that
but wouldn't you expect that succeeding
freshman classes would have kept
doing the same thing because they pass
it on one to another
what if it was or if it was just one
three or four year cohort who then went
and carried it somewhere else
in a way that's good news because it
would mean that these people will just
keep getting older and older in their
current jobs
and then they'll become these greying
people who are you know strangely angry
but then there's this whole generation
below them
that aren't it seems to me that usually
these things are passed on
to the people who are slightly younger
and somehow
that didn't happen out and it may be
just i'm speaking from colombia
where for mysterious reasons nothing
like that ever really
happened so i maybe feel more sanguine
because protests at colombia are small
and brief as opposed to there having
ever been anything that made the news
other than
the controver and ahsoka what's his
controversy the mattress controversy and
that's a really very different
set of issues than what we're talking
about here although there's a there's an
intersection
but i don't know i i hope i'm right too
only because
it would be frightening for this country
to be taken over by people who refuse to
reason
and don't know that that's what they're
doing they don't know they're refusing
to reason
they think that there's certain issues
upon which there can be no reasoning
and you literally can't talk to them
they cannot be reasoned with and put
them in positions of power and next
thing you know the country does start to
disappear
that is that is a very frightening
[Music]
prospect